même ça bonjour merci d'être heures ou
alors première question êtes vous
surpris par cette victoire des
indépendantistes
non c'était annoncé et pas que le moment
où les indépendantistes avait
démissionné du gouvernement
il pouvait espérer retrouver une
majorité oui majorité dans le nouveau
gouvernement
puisque au congrès est guère manqué que
quelques voix pour être majoritaire
qu'est-ce qui a été quand même la sûreté
c'est plus les veilles océaniens légende
est principalement des idées assez de
wallis et futuna qui sont prêts nombre
en nouvelle calédonie les trois voire on
crève les védas et amiens se sont portés
sur les listes indépendantistes ce qui a
permis aux indépendantistes d'avoir s'il
voit six sièges sur 11 dont nouveau
gouvernement
quelles pourraient être les
répercussions politiques de ce
changement de gouvernement
alors il faut dire que ce changement de
gouvernement il va dans le sens de la
aussi indépendantiste s'est confirmée au
référendum de cap 2020 et elle n'a pas
changé énormément les choses puisque les
indépendants qu'ils vont avoir la main
pour construire le projet d'une nouvelle
société néo calédoniennes dans laquelle
ils prennent leur place et qui est un
projet qui puisse ouvrir à une
indépendance en partenariat avec la
france puisque c'est ce que la majorité
des indépendantistes mettant en avant
aujourd'hui
cette prise de pouvoir des
indépendantistes avant le rappel
survient un an avant un probable
troisième référendum qui est prévue en
2022 pour une possible indépendance de
la nouvelle calédonie ce nouveau
gouvernement pourrait changer
les choses on sait que les deux premiers
référendum et bien n'avait pas été
gagnée
oui alors qu'ici c'est vrai n'était pas
nécessaire de gagner la présidence du
gouvernement pour enclencher le
référendum il fallait une majorité des
deux tiers dans de toute façon
l'engagement du troisième référendum
aurait lieu
il pourrait avoir lieu au plus tard à la
fin 2022 il ya 18 mois à partir du
moment où le processus est enclenché
la question est moins le référendum lui
même que l'après référendum que ce soit
une victoire du non dans les loyalistes
une victoire unique soit les
indépendantistes problème est de
disputer dès maintenant et là les
indépendantistes en avoir la main pour
lancer ces discussions ne discutait sur
la paix référendum c'est à dire sur le
type de société que les calédoniens
veulent établir en partenariat avec la
france n'at il s'agit pas d'une
indépendance sèche
il s'agit de la naissance d'une nouvelle
forme inventé en partenariat avec la
france pour qu'il ait une continuité
dans les actions que la france a mené
avec les indépendantistes et les
loyalistes depuis 30 ans depuis l'accord
de nouméa de 1998 dont cuche et c'est ça
l'enjeu est donc ce n'est pas simplement
de gagner au référendum petit ami
qu'elle que soit il n'y aura aucun 20h
voulu acceptera l'indépendance sèche ou
un maintien dans la france sans les
indépendantistes
donc faut absolument trouver la voie de
dialogue
je pense que le gouvernement est en
position pour aller l'enfance merci
beaucoup en tout cas alban bensa d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin je
rappelle que vous êtes anthropologue et
spécialiste
nouvelle calédonie et de la culture du
peuple kanak